servat d'achat au comptant mais bientôt
on diffuse journée avec un plongeur de
couleur plutôt rose
voilà alors jeté sur un jeu complètement
what the fuck puisqu'on est sous l'eau
en mode call of duty version harpon avec
des robes avec nous et là dessus toi il
te manque dessus je pus tôt or il est
mort au [ __ ] flash
je me suis pris un gros je me suis pris
un gros pire qu'un grec d'ailleurs est
ce que tu aimes la kronenbourg
enfin la belle ayem l'écrou de roue
qu'un mongai font qu'une me bouffe et
regardons cacher le mal bah là je suis
grave dans le mal je vois rien à temps
il a vu naître son petit couteau aux
abus des lieux à temps en fait je crois
qu'il va jouer au couteau mais moi je
pense que le couteau en fait c'était
facile pour bat pour aux côtés
y a plein
ce qu'on peut présenter le jeu en 4 mots
jeux indépendants sous marin coûtait
alors également il ya un avion sous
l'eau ce pilote est mort le pilote n'est
pas désintégré pleuvoir aux attentes en
temps je me fais je sais bien c'est
pinocchio il ya un emploi mais un
habitué aux gens et leurs douze hommes
et c'est pour ça qu'ils sont crashés en
fait c'était parti bordel de merde lever
la tête en bois
c'est lui que tu veux pas venir m'aider
parce que sinon je pense que je faisais
la manette gc
donc c'est vrai je te vois je te vois
j'arrive en moyenne sur le couteau y
gros et j'arrivais mais je sais pas il
ya un truc qui m'a tuer j'ai pas compris
ce qui s'est passé est ce que c'était un
calamar wee herman cain lamarre d'une
taille de 8 mètres de long mais comme
mon pénis lors ce cas c'est le droit
d'entrer dans ce jeu ce qu'on retrouve
quand même des niveaux où rien ne lui ce
pays vous bientôt niveau 2 mois et 22
jours de jeu quoi je fais à peu près de
juger débloquer le couteau mon gars qui
courent mieux sous l'eau que les autres
doigt le coût d'un beau tir ouillage
impossible à rouler c'est ça oui c'est
ça c'est ça donc j'ai fait des blagues
nulles au passage tu penses que je
préfère ne pas écouter ma petite taille
allant du bleu au niveau de l'avion dans
une clinique
je sais pas je tape la causette avec un
requin obama me taper la causette
ça peut qu être tu ailles paul sarault
gaye porte des têtes c'était nul
nous allons faire une seconde de silence
pour cette blague gueule
as tu en viens aux faucons faut qu'on
leur tende un guet-apens pas le mot de
trop vite tu parles attendent toujours
d'être écrite sous loue mon bien
attendant tantrique ailleurs j'ai mené
j'ai fait mon but j'ai coupé la cour et
n'oublier personne
le nombre d'arrivées à thônex plus
direct moins bien avec quoi équiper
éventrant six gymnastes incessamment
observait ainsi c'est alors qu'un jour
seul le requin bien là vient la viande
en attendant les verts yve c'est madame
madame est à déposer le faire toi
derrière toi du cac bic
quoique je suis mort attendaient un choc
tel job rétrograde ou toujours grouille
il s'est pris un harpon j'arrive dans
les vosges arrive je sais pas une balle
perdue ça a dit qu'il va mieux mais il
est pas mal fait on sans déconner pour
un gens dépendants [ __ ] fédensieu car
c'est bon les 6-7 ans maintenant mais on
ne lève 5 centimes chacun c'est pour toi
mon gars attention les intérêts
immobiliers allait mieux on se méfiait
combattre ce genre qu'on bouge pas avant
regarde le long il va arriver regarde
toujours vers le haut
il arrive il arrive que la peau compte
encore un attentat tandis que faire
laisser faire qui va arriver toute
l'histoire des guides ou wav regarde il
fait chaud alors c'est quoi ça j'enlève
j'arrive nul du tarmac et que c'était
quand même un fusil à pompe
c'est d'ailleurs c'est un peu tard pour
cheat et je peux dire mais quand tu mets
silencieux dessus il pourrait encore
plus de patate non je déconne à tanger
tétouan je suis là regarde la morosité
bonjour bonjour je viens de me gratter
de vente qu'aux anciens voilà j'ai dit
attends je récolte des mollahs
oh [ __ ] mais tu es sans faire exprès
c'est plutôt mon cutter et cauterets et
la rive regard ailleurs je vois le
sommet d'un ferry des attentions vannes
en motos venues en autocars à
cache-cache tiendrait enfin qu'elle
cherchait à la flash vient d'asie les
alizés ckoi et dès qu'ils rentrent pour
lâcher une flat choquer ou la chine
flash tous les deux en même temps
attends attends mais comment il va des
armures attend toi t'as pas le mot gay à
travers cette allure est ce que moi mais
pas de la traverse le oui toi aussi wii
dont chloé les mecs on est des mecs
comme ça donc pas atteint mais mais
qu'on a tellement de kings of leon et un
jour dieu tu es toujours votre bâton mon
dieu non le mec et [ __ ] j'ai
enregistré à vous reporter aux
sous-marins ya vraiment pouvoir
alors lu mon gars ou leucate ne tue boom
bien en âge d'être bénie kebano mais on
sent trop shaktoi hop l'eponge des gars
qui le stresse plus de son budget
débloqué mec tard marié ternheim et
ouais voilà ça mange des pâtes et le
bruitage bienfaits du monde les chiens
éduqués ou tous la même taille mme gao
la longue shot le long shot en charge à
lui si mme cottin étape c'est le surnom
est encore plus qu'après avoir bu un
litre de qoqani et d'haïti et de peace
humaine très désolé j'ai mes règles et
que tu fais là aussi je veux juste dire
un secret qu'un jardin et je vais te
montrer quelque chose vient pas [ __ ]
mais tout est plus jeune que des petits
doigts encore merci loge la tête plus
rapide que moi alors quelqu'un aille
sans risque sicar tina car étant il
reste quatorze secondes un gage j'espère
que tout le monde regarde acquis face
bongo [ __ ] mais you want your mom il
s'appelle et pour ce faire
non pas que prendre vidéo
vous allez ici